good afternoon everyone it's my pleasure
to introduce Dr Mara Carlin performing
the duties of the Deputy under secretary
of defense for policy who will provide
some brief remarks about the August
optimal pathway announced by President
Biden yesterday this is a trilateral
commitment space plan for Australia to
acquire conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarines please note
Dr Carlin will have time for a few
questions afterwards and then must
depart I'd ask that you please limit
your questions to August given that's
her Focus here today and then after a
brief pause I'll Stick Around to provide
some non-ocus updates and answer
questions as well so thank you for your
assistance on this Dr Carlin over to you
man all right thanks so much good
afternoon it's great to see y'all
yesterday you heard from President Biden
prime minister Alvin easy and prime
minister sunac on the agreement for
Australia to acquire a conventionally
armed nuclear-powered submarine
capability through the Australia United
Kingdom United States enhanced security
partnership or our caucus yesterday
concluded our 18-month thorough and
expert-led consultation period to
identify the optimal pathway for
Australia to acquire this capability
while setting the highest nuclear
non-proliferation standard this plan
will deliver on that commitment and lift
all three nations submarine industrial
bases and undersea capabilities
enhancing deterrence and promoting
stability in the indo-pacific for the
last seven decades our three countries
have stood shoulder to shoulder along
with our allies and partners to help
sustain peace and stability in the
indo-pacific the optimal pathway will
sustain that in the decisive decades
ahead as the National Security strategy
and National defense strategy describe
the United States must pursue a free
open and secure world to protect our
national interests and those of our
allies and our partners August advances
this goal by building our military
capabilities and those of two of our
very closest allies enabling closer
military planning and cooperation it is
a gen generational opportunity to
enhance the National Security of all
three nations as the president shared in
his remarks yesterday the optimal
pathway will deliver deterrence across
several phases under the first phase of
the optimal pathway the United States
and the United Kingdom will immediately
increase Port visits of conventionally
armed nuclear-powered submarines in
Australia and then as early as 2027 will
begin rotating through Australia under
submarine rotational Force West this
deployment will ensure Australian
Personnel can continue familiarizing
themselves with how these vessels
operate how they are properly maintained
and how we can continue safely operating
together the increased presence of U.S
submarines will buttress Regional
stability and support the safe
development of Australian stewardship of
its own Sovereign conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarine Enterprise
in the next phase the United States
intends to sell three virginia-class
submarines to Australia in the 2030s
with the potential to sell up to two
more if needed this will provide
Australia with a conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarine capability
prior to their enduring Sovereign
capability coming online you will see
three Allied and highly interoperable
SSN fleets operating in the indo-pacific
the Final Phase will be our support for
what we call SSN August a Next
Generation conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarine designed and
constructed by Australia and the UK and
incorporating cutting-edge U.S
Technologies in the propulsion plant
combat control and weapon systems
Australia's acquisition of ssns will
bolster the capabilities of one of our
strongest allies by increasing the Royal
Australian Navy's range survivability
and striking power thus strengthening
deterrence in the indo-pacific
every phase of the optimal pathway will
set the highest nuclear
non-proliferation standards moreover
August will diversify U.S posture in the
indo-pacific offering new locations from
which U.S forces can operate and August
will strengthen U.S and Allied submarine
industrial capacity which is key to
modernizing innovating and maintaining
our military and economic Competitive
Edge today and in the future three
highly capable Allied and intraoperable
submarine forces will strengthen U.S
national security and buttress stability
in the indo-pacific for decades to come
we are also working to modernize our
information sharing and Export Control
Systems which is necessary for the
effective implementation of August as
the national defense strategy outlines
the capacity to share information with
key allies and partners is of critical
importance to how the United States
deters aggression and succeeds in
contingencies we will work closely with
the U.S government including the
Congress of course and the United
Kingdom and Australia to identify
obstacles to information sharing and to
develop Innovative rapid and scalable
solutions to develop to deliver on the
president's vision for this historic
partnership and with that I'd be
delighted to take your questions thank
man right go to the edge professions yes
sir
have you had any Direct Communications
with other militaries
um
airing concerns or issues about the
orcas deal and if so what have they been
and also just on the selection of the
virginia-class submarines that you you
will eventually sell to Australia what's
the criteria for which submarines you
select and how and when you deliver them
I want to make sure I understand the
first part of your questions when you've
talked about Communications with
militaries are you citing specific
allies partners
China
Asian countries any other foreign
military great uh we have had a number
of conversations with our allies and our
partners in civilian channels and
Military channels of course throughout
the consultative period and then of
course in the run-up to yesterday's
announcement and have heard a
substantial amount of enthusiasm from
them for this historic game-changing uh
partnership regarding engagements with
the People's Republic of China the state
department did do that and I would refer
to you you I would refer you to them for
the substance of that dialogue I would
of course highlight what you've heard
often from secretary Austin which is
that open communication between our two
countries is important for risk
management and for understanding what
one another is thinking
and then on your second question
regarding uh Virginia
um you know why we chose that we looked
at a wide number of options it has been
a robust and very busy 18 months of uh
of consultations and trying to look at
wide variety of options in terms of
which submarine specifically will go uh
that will will go to rotate for
submarine rotational forces West that's
really going to be figured out through
our normal military processes of such
efforts
bro
okay uh thank you very much for doing
this I have two questions about the
submarine rotational Force West uh can
you say the new rotational force will
increase the total number of U.S
submarine operating in the Western
Pacific compared to today
and then do you have another question
yeah then secondly can you tell us uh
can you talk a little bit about
advantage of having a rotational
presence of the U.S submarine outside of
the second island chain in terms of
deterring Chinese aggression in the
region
on on that first one uh
heparating capable submarines around the
indo-pacific is really critical for
security and stability and I think that
really tracks nicely to your next
question which look to be very clear
August is not about any one country it
is about the need for security stability
and prosperity in the indo-pacific and
our three countries of course have a
robust history of collaborating together
this is going to take us to another
level of interoperability I would
highlight the significance of sharing
this information with Australia as you
all probably know the last time we did
so it was 1958 so it's really a sign of
just how close this relationship is for
that to really occur in a responsible
way it's important that Australia
develop stewardship practices and that's
why we have developed this multi-phased
Mutual commitments approach
let's go to Wolf
thank you
um regarding the Virginia class
submarines that that Australia will
purchased in the 2030s has has a
specific model been selected or is that
something that's a little bit down the
road and it will basically be what's on
the production line for the US is
purchasing at that point will they be
equipped with the the vpm to increase
missile capacity or is it something
tailored to Australia specifically
so first of all it's worth noting that
Australia will get these Subs in just
about a decade that is frankly faster
than I suspect a lot of folks might have
expected when this whole effort was
announced just 18 months ago Australia
will be purchasing a mix of new new
submarines and old submarines and right
now it looks like it will be two with
the potential to have excuse me it will
be three with the potential for two more
uh if needed as I noted earlier uh the
the cohort of folks looked at a wide
range of different options and really
came came down with Virginia as the re
as the right approach uh and Virginia
payload module will not be be a part of
it I think the three countries saw that
that didn't make sense uh as you no
doubt know well of course these
submarines are going to be especially
special though because of their stealth
their range and their endurance so they
really will will be kind of a meaningful
meaningful deterrent in the region
go to gym
all right it's good to see you
um I'm the info sharing going back to
the question you answered just just a
little bit before is that is that a real
showstopper I mean these these countries
are all five eye participants you don't
really anticipate that being a a problem
with the info sharing with Australia do
you you know Jim allies and partners are
at the heart of the national defense
strategy right they're a center of
gravity for realizing that 2022 National
defense strategy and we know we have to
lower the barriers to working with them
and information is just a piece of it
you're exactly right that these are two
of our very closest allies who we have
stood shoulder to shoulder with for much
of the last hundred years or so uh
nevertheless nevertheless we have
processes that have to be figured out
and to ensure that both pillars of
August right there are two pillars today
we're very focused on pillar one which
is the uh the the conventionally armed
nuclear-powered submarines but there's
also pillar too right this cooperation
on Advanced capabilities we know for
that to be realized we're going to need
very uh clear transparent robust
information sharing practices it's a
great case study these are exactly the
right to allies to make it real and we
look forward to working with our
colleagues around the US government
including the Congress to to make that a
reality
Joe
hi thanks for doing this
um Joe gold defense news um just to
follow up on Jim's question I mean what
are the can you drill down a little bit
to talk about what are the specific
obstacles do you have a sense I mean
after 18 months do you have a sense of
what some of the
the pieces of itar and what kind of
information sharing needs to get changed
Joe we've spent a
mental figuring out how we can ensure
that we deliver on this historic game
changing pledge by the three heads of
state and so we've looked hard at the
different changes that might need to
happen but I would say that there's
probably more to be done along those
lines but I can assure you that we will
do all we can to both deliver on the
submarines and to deliver on the
advanced capabilities piece we are in
very close consultation with our
colleagues at the state department on
the itarp specifically and also with our
our colleagues in in Congress but on the
whole I think we've all been pleased to
see robust bipartisan support for making
this a reality and really recognizing
the sort of generational leap that we
see in this Alliance
thank you very much ma'am appreciate it
thank you
all right thank you all very much uh
just a few things at the top and then
I'll get right to your questions so
first of all I would like to highlight
U.S European commands statement released
earlier today confirming that two
Russian su-27 aircraft conducted unsafe
and unprofessional and unprofessional
intercept with a U.S Air Force
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance unmanned MQ-9 aircraft
that was operating within International
airspace over the Black Sea today to
recap at approximately 703 a.m Central
European Time one of the Russian su-27
aircraft struck the propeller of the
MQ-9 causing U.S forces to have to bring
the MQ-9 down in international waters
several times before the Collision the
su-27s dumped fuel on and flew in front
of the MQ-9 in a reckless and
unprofessional manner this incident
demonstrates a lack of competence in
addition to being unsafe and
unprofessional
U.S air forces in Europe Air Forces
Africa routinely fly aircraft throughout
Europe over Sovereign territory and
throughout International airspace in
coordination with applicable host nation
and international laws in order to
bolster Collective European Defense and
security these missions support Allied
partner and U.S national objectives
as the U.S air forces in Europe Air
Forces Africa Commander emphasized in
European command statement quote U.S and
Allied aircraft will continue to operate
in international airspace and we call on
the Russians to conduct themselves
professionally and safely
in separate news secretary Austin
concluded a successful visit to the
Middle East region last week where he
met with leaders in Jordan Iraq Egypt
and Israel the week-long trip served a
deep and defense Partnerships and
enabled the exchange of views on shared
Regional and Global Security challenges
specific topics of discussion include
ongoing coalition-led defeat Isis
operations in Iraq and Syria the
concerning range of threats posed by
Iran including its destabilizing
Regional activities and provision of
unmanned aerial systems to Russia for
use in their unprovoked war against
Ukraine and implementing commitments
made by Israeli and Palestinian senior
officials in Aqaba Jordan and the
importance of de-escalating violence and
restoring calm in the West Bank the
secretary also had the opportunity to
talk to a number of U.S service members
currently serving in the U.S Central
Command area of responsibility and thank
them and their families for their
commitment to Mission service and
safeguarding our nation
and finally secretary Austin and
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
General milley will host the 10th
meeting of the Ukraine defense contact
group tomorrow the meeting will be
hosted virtually here in the Pentagon
and will allow for the secretary the
chairman and Senior defense leaders from
around the world to discuss ongoing
efforts to provide Ukraine with the
means and resources it needs to defend
itself from Russian aggression
additional information on tomorrow's
meeting will be forthcoming and with
that I will take your questions we'll
start with the Reuters Phil
Terry or anyone else in the U.S military
reached out to his Russian counterpart
or anyone else's counterparts from
Russia and regarding the MQ-9 uh you
know what what can you detail a little
more what its mission was and where was
being piloted from yeah sure
um so in terms of uh secretary Austin uh
talking to his counterpart not at this
time to my knowledge uh
DOD officials have not spoken
specifically to Russian authorities on
this particular incident I do know that
the state department is raising our
concerns about the incident directly
with the Russian government so I'd refer
you to them for details on that in terms
of the the mission of the MQ-9 as I
mentioned it's an ISR platform you know
these these aircraft have been flying
over the Black Sea region for some time
to include before the current conflict
started it is an important and busy
International Waterway uh and so it is
uh not an uncommon mission for us to be
flying an international airspace
was this aircraft armed uh so I'm not
going to get into the specific uh
profile of this particular aircraft as
you know the MQ-9 does have the ability
to be armed it was again conducting an
ISR mission in international airspace
something that we've been doing for some
time in terms of the types of tactic
techniques and procedures that we take
to protect our aircraft I'm not going to
get into the specifics I think the key
Point here is that while intercepts in
and of themselves are not that uncommon
the fact that this type of behavior from
these Russian Pilots that is uncommon
and unfortunate and unsafe and so again
what Echo General heckers call on the
Russians to continue to
fly safely thank you Liz
was this Collision itself an accident on
Russia's behalf and is the U.S
responding as such
um so
you know we are continuing to assess
exactly what happened but I think based
on the actions of the Russian Pilots
it's clear that it was unsafe
unprofessional
um and I think the actions speak for
themselves what we what we saw again
were fighter aircraft dumping fuel in
front of this UAV and then getting so
close to the aircraft that it actually
damaged the propeller on the MQ-9 we we
assessed that it likely caused some
damage to the Russian aircraft as well
um to our knowledge well we know that
the aircraft the Russian aircraft did
land I'm not going to go into where they
landed
but again it just demonstrative of uh
very unprofessional unsafe airmanship on
the part of these Pilots one more
question sorry
um will the U.S try to recover this
drone uh so I'm not I don't have
anything right now to provide in terms
of recovery operations if we have any
updates to provide and we'll be sure to
do that thank you
David
is there video of the incident are you
going to release the video
where in the Black Sea did it happen how
close
to Russian airspace
and did you say that this particular
Reaper was unarmed again I didn't say
whether it was or was not I'm not going
to get into the particular Mission
profile of this aircraft it was
conducting an ISR Mission
um
in terms of the specifics David I'm not
going to at this point be able to get
more specific other than the Black Sea
region in international airspace well
well clear of uh of any type of
um yeah it was International airspace
and I'm sorry the other part of your
question the video yes so we are going
through the the declassification process
now and we'll keep you updated on that
front in terms of imagery associated
with this incident
address
I'm laser focused on your question now
this is a very quick one um you haven't
said Reaper but he said Reaper is it
accurate to say it's MQ-9 Reaper
I'm just going to stick with MQ-9 yep
thanks Joe
hi thanks so much Pat um
the an MQ-9 potentially contains
sensitive technology is the U.S military
undertaking any effort to recover the
MQ-9 is it in the is it in the waters of
the Black Sea is Russia recovered it
um is there a U.S naval asset in the in
the region that could undertake that
recovery thanks yeah so uh again I'm not
going to get into the specifics of
what's on this particular aircraft other
than again it's an ISR platform because
of the damage we were in a position to
have to essentially
um crash it into the Black Sea uh to my
knowledge at this point in time
the Russians have not recovered that
aircraft but again in terms of
our recovery efforts don't have any
updates to provide right now I'd refer
you to navier in terms of what assets
they may have in that region thank you
[Music]
thank you General uh regarding the North
Korea's summary in Ranchi the Strategic
cruise missiles recently North Korea has
announced that it is possible to monitor
nuclear warhead on a strategic cruise
missiles what is the Readiness of the
United States against the escalate
provocations such as the nuclear
provocation by the North Korea
let me just make sure I understand
what's the Readiness of the U.S to
respond to a nuclear provocation by
North Korea
well I think we've been very clear that
we're North Korea to employ a nuclear
weapon it would be the end of the North
Korean regime but again our Focus
continues to be on working very closely
with our allies and our partners in the
region to deter aggression to preserve
security and stability in the region and
that will continue to be our our Focus
if you go to Carla
clarification
what did the fighter jet what did he
strike the the MQ-9 with was it the wing
was it yeah uh I can't tell you
specifically what portion of the
aircraft but uh is the fact that it
essentially ran into the MQ-9 okay thank
you and then just separately on Ukraine
there's reports out there from the the
battlefield that the ukrainians are
running out of Munitions they're having
shortages is that a concern for the
Pentagon and what's the Pentagon doing
to alleviate that problem yeah so as
we've been doing since the beginning of
this campaign we're continuing to do
everything that we can to ensure that
we're meeting Ukraine's needs whether
it's ammunition whether it's air defense
armor uh you know you've heard us talk
extensively about that tomorrow's
discussion of course will be another
opportunity to bring the International
Community together to focus on Ukraine's
most urgent needs to include ammunition
and so uh again that will continue to be
our focus and and you've heard secretary
Austin and others say that we're
committed to making sure that they have
what they need to be successful
their assessment why
is there an assessment that the Pentagon
has on why they're running out of
ammunition is it because they're just
expending it too fast is it not making
it to the battlefield in time what's
your exactly yeah really so I'd have to
refer you to the ukrainians to talk
about their specific efforts to supply
their individual units again we're
working very closely with them and our
International Partners to get them what
they need
um and and I think it's also important
to kind of take a step back and look at
the progress that has been made while
recognizing the fact that there still is
a tough fight ahead particularly as we
go into the the spring and summer and so
our our Focus again is going to be
working with national armaments
directors with the ukrainians to get
them the ammunition they need and get
that to the front line units as quickly
as possible let me go back over to this
side of the room yes sir
thank you can you guide us through the
timeline of the MQ-9 intercept uh
we have that the aircraft was struck at
703 eastern time but uh how long were
the sukhoys with the aircraft beforehand
and were there any Radio Calls between
radio communications either from the
Russians or from the United States
yeah so on the latter part of your
question no none that I'm aware of
um
and uh I would ask that you go back and
confirm this with UConn but but based on
the information I have here it seems
like uh
approximately
30 to 40 minutes uh they were flying in
the vicinity of this MQ-9 uh and then at
703 is when the
73 a.m Central European Time is when
they collided causing it to crash so
awesome
the U.S forces has had to bring down the
the aircraft does that mean that the
United States piloted it to the crash
site or was it struck by Amazon yeah we
brought it down
so
is there any U.S naval assets currently
in in Black Sea again I'd have to refer
you to navier for any details on
particular Assets in the region thank
you Laura
thanks
um can you talk a little bit more about
the damage to the MQ-9 was it unflyable
and and that's why you had to bring it
down and then can you say a little bit
more about how often this kind of thing
happens in over the Black Sea that
Russian aircraft harass U.S drones and
and other aircraft
yeah so I don't have any statistics in
front of me in terms of intercepts but
again as I highlighted the fact that
uh
intercepts of aircraft are not uncommon
in and of themselves it's not obviously
a daily occurrence the vast majority of
those intercepts are what we would
consider safe and professional just
wanting to see what's there right you're
flying alongside it to to be able to see
what's there in this particular case
though again they collided with the
aircraft damaging the propeller and
essentially putting in a situation where
is unfiable and uncontrollable so we
brought it down thank you time for a few
more go here and then
hi sir thanks I just wanted to check to
confirm any communication with allies
such as turkey about potential recovery
of the Drone and is there any concern
that Russia could provide the Drone to
Iran if it recovers it uh so that that
would be hypothetical again Russia does
not have the Drone so that would be a
hypothetical question in terms of
working with allies and partners I don't
have anything to announce here but if
and when we do we'll be sure to let you
know thank you go to fatty and then
we'll come back over here they'll blast
to you
uh thank you General so on um I know you
don't want to share lots of information
especially intelligence information but
are you able to say whether the MQ-9 was
flying
um near Ukraine or near the Crimea
Peninsula and then I believe you said if
I heard right that the Russians did not
recover the uh the Drone however have
you seen any effort by the Russian Navy
to try to recover the Drone thank you
yeah so on your latter question there
Friday I'm not going to get into that
um in terms of where it was flying
um it was well clear of any territory in
Ukraine it was over International in
international airspace over
International water so thank you Nancy
thank you um during secretary Austin's
visit to Egypt he held meetings with
officials even though all press were
banned from covering it past defense
Chiefs when they've been in a similar
situation have refused to proceed given
that the Biden Administration has said
that one of its key pillars in terms of
foreign policy is that one presented
with the a choice between autocrats and
democracies that it stands with
democracy can you help us understand why
the secretary decided to proceed with
those trips given the ban and should we
expect that going forward thank you
thank you so our relationship with Egypt
is obviously a very important uh
strategic partnership uh the secretary
did appreciate the opportunity to meet
with his counterparts and talk about
that I will tell you when it come when
it came to the Press coverage of that
portion having looked further into it
the Egyptians loved lived up to what
they had agreed upon some of the Lessons
Learned out of that was in terms of
making sure that we were on the same
sheet when it came to understanding
press access and so we will continue to
work that I'm sorry
beforehand that there would be
there would be we did not agree to a ban
on journalists we agreed to have
official photographers we did have one
reporter come into one of the sessions
but then a portion that was going to be
open to the Press was subsequently not
held and therefore there was not an
opportunity to cover that but again
sometimes these meetings are are very
small sometimes there's not the
opportunity for media to come in but
again it's something that we've noted
and will continue to work closely with
governments as we visit to ensure that
there's press access
thank you
sir
just regarding the budget for the last
few years the services have pursued a
divest to invest strategy and Congress
hasn't necessarily bought into that this
year the Air Force is looking to retire
more than 300 aircraft double the amount
last year again Congress last year
didn't give that full amount is there a
sense that things have changed on the
hill that there's a willingness to
approve greater divestment or is this
now becoming kind of a cat and mouse
game of shoot with a higher number
knowing you're going to get less to try
to get to where you want to be
well when it comes to the Air Force
budget specifically I of course would
refer you to them to talk in specifics
and and I don't want to answer for
congress what I will say is having
observed this process I do think like
anything there's a continuing dialogue
in terms of what the services require to
meet their mission requirements and and
working closely with Congress and with
the Department of Defense to identify
what those offsets might be in order to
ensure that we can modernize uh you know
throughout all the services and so I
think in a lot of ways is that
communication has increased you're
seeing some of the the fruits of that
labor but again I'd refer you to the Air
Force for specifics on their budget okay
thank you very much everybody appreciate
it